i'm just gonna preface that i flew in
this morning at 4am which is why i'm
just so crazy today but honestly what's
kind of sad is i did not fly in at 4am
and i feel like i'm kind of keeping up
with your crazy
hey guys it's alex so today is a super
special day because one i'm gonna be
making cinnamon rolls and two i don't
have to do it alone no she doesn't it's
madeline what's up you might recognize
madeleine as cheryl blossom on riverdale
i'm in the mid for chaos but today she
is going to be helping me make cinnamon
rolls for taste madeleine is actually
vegan i am her whole entire life
these are going to be so good i always
like a challenge as you guys may know
and i haven't made much vegan food in my
life you can tell me if they taste
different i guess i'll be the judge of
that hope this isn't a river fail
[Music]
we're back and we're ready to bake
madeleine do you do much baking i'm
gonna be honest the last time that i
baked i baked vegan cinnamon rolls once
with one of my co-stars and it went
terribly wrong we did like a wrap you're
like slapping the dough and it was just
not good well luckily i am a expert in
the kitchen
okay we're gonna start with our wet
ingredients oh lovely so sugar is
technically considered a wet ingredient
yeah actually it is because if you
dissolve sugar it like turns into a
liquid so we have our vegan almond milk
vegan butter organic sugar
and yeast okay wow to our bowl this is
already too official for me this almond
milk is room temperature and the butter
is just melted so it's a little bit warm
we're doing this sugar we'll hold on
that let's mix this up first this smells
disgusting
yeah it's alive is it vegan then
technically
that's like another ethical question
do a little sprinkle sprinkle all across
the surface of the
perfect born to sprinkle yeast baby
okay now we have to wait so as we said
yeast is alive so it needs to activate
so it foams right it starts to foam yeah
oh my gosh well i made these a year ago
oh right so tell me a little bit about
yourself don't you what do you want to
know how long have you worked at tasty
for uh just over two years now that's a
lot of videos do you cook well as a
vegan you kind of have to but i'm not
gonna say i'm good at it
i'm more of like i eat for nutrition
purposes i eat for just pure enjoyment
see it's really foaming up
it's like kind of like i think that's
you shaking the table
making it look like it's alive but yeah
oh
timer yeast is ready we've got the flour
i've got the flour
into our wet mixture there you go
get that right in there salt will kill
your yeast so you don't really want to
have that are we creating them like are
we murdering right now well no we're
trying not to murder these places so you
can add that in okay
pro salt adder
thank you
wooden spoon stir away show me how you
do it yeah show me how you do it you
know it's really hard there's a specific
technique i just feel like this is where
i would start messing it up
it's stirring so i'm gonna switch you
out because my arm's tired good thing i
didn't get my workout today man you guys
make this look so easy like this is
actually you know we do we do we cut out
all the mistakes
keep going girl keep going i'm working
up a sweater in the kitchen baby
literally i cancelled my gym membership
because i get it all day long this looks
great and that is a vegan cinnamon roll
honestly basically
do a little scrapey scrape a little
taffy tap and then a little plastic wrap
so we want to cover this up and let this
dough rest for about an hour well we
have an hour to kill so let's get to
know you a little bit it's good to know
you a little bit
they already know me well enough what's
the go-to meal that you cut so i do like
a red lentil pasta
with like sauteed garlic and olive oil
and then some like steamed spinach there
you go she's a pro guys so you said you
were a big fan of tasty what is your
favorite video oh my god don't make me
pick was a giant macaroon
macaron giant macaron
i like them all though honestly it's
like this is my morning routine i get a
little cup of coffee from downstairs i
walk back upstairs and then i watch my
little tc videos how do you take your
coffee pea milk pea milk p-e-a peanuts
i was like what do vegans eat nowadays
this gets a little weird
i actually very much prefer almond and
coconut milk to regular milk so you know
what i'm kind of a vegan
kind of so we're gonna unwrap this this
is when it starts getting really intense
though right it is a little tight yeah
but you know what i'll walk you through
it can't wait we're gonna put a half a
cup of flour onto our dough wow there
you go
it's a lot of sprinkling in this recipe
i'm gonna test it out i'm just going to
work the flour into the dough i'm like
mesmerized so it's not sticky i'm going
to turn this out onto our table i can
get that extra flour out on there
because
it'll be good for kneading a seasoned
pro
i know dough why do we keep writing i
don't know
don't do it again
you can over knead right isn't that a
thing you don't want to over knead it
because it would be really tough to work
with how do you know it's over needed
it's just you know
a feeling you've got to get that touch
when you're kneading you want to work
with the
heel the thing that's the heel of your
palm of your palm well if it's not it is
now so just kind of like work it do a
little pulley tug yeah there you go do
it do you remember this part from a year
ago i don't think i did this part i
didn't have a rolling pin either so we
have to get a little creative you know
you can actually use a wine bottle i
didn't know that at the time we want to
make it a nice kind of like round ball
you were doing this so quickly and not
even looking she's like
[Music]
and then i'm gonna put a towel on it and
it will disappear
just kidding we just want to let that
sit for about five minutes so it kind of
loosens up because it would be really
hard to roll out
okay
set another timer oh cute i didn't
realize i could do that cause i'm
wearing an apron
our dough is still here
the rolling out of the dough another
step that i skipped what what did you do
we're gonna sprinkle some flour down
just to make sure our dough doesn't get
stuck to the surface and then we're
going to use our roll this is a massive
rolling pin
i'm going to give you like a border of
flour okay and that's what you should
get to need to get to there all right no
pressure
oh it looks good oh yeah do i just keep
doing that two rolls out of that oh
that's okay
just put it back you can do a little oop
oh wow oh you know a little fancy there
you go it's all in the wrist you know
don't be afraid to just get your hands
in there if you need to kind of reshape
where it's going what shape should it be
we want a rectangle rectangle okay okay
so let's do this way yeah that way there
you go
yeah you know what we're looking pretty
good it's rustic it's it is rustic
that's my word for when things are
looking beautiful yeah oh she's so
pretty she's she's very beautiful
rustic so we're gonna take all that
butter that's the beauty of a cinnamon
butter so i'm just gonna lather this
softened butter kind of on to our dough
do you
eat a lot of vegan butter i mean like on
my toast sometimes do like a nice
coconut oil wow i'm so much more vegan
than i thought you are like pretty much
a vegan can i go for that let's do it
should be faster i feel like i should be
no you're
whoa double done when you use your hands
the warmth of your hands will kind of
melt the butter so it's a little bit
easier it sounds like you really want to
use your hands oh you want to go just go
here we'll do it
kind of pretty good see you get the
spatula and i'll do the hands gorgeous i
love this is the best part of your job
eating it oh for sure yeah we eat all
day long that's such a great thing is it
now we have
more
sugar if you want to give that a good
sprinkle all over our dough
oh it's really sprinkly you could
probably
just it's going really well brown sugar
has molasses in it so it won't sprinkle
as nicely as a granulated sugar but it
gives a really great like deeper flavor
than white granulated sugar would so
beautiful it's like little gold flakes
all that sugar delish make it rain sugar
base
and now the cinnamon our final
ingredient wow cinnamon smells real good
you really can't mess this up that's the
beauty that's why you picked this one
for me two months together make an
excellent team
we want to get a really tight roll so
i'm just going to kind of tuck this side
in and then work my way down and then
i'll start working my way back oh wow
it's like a very small roll no it will
grow the cinnamon roll would be great
but i didn't realize you do it so tight
if it's not tight then you're not going
to get that nice spiral looking
roll
you know go slow baking doesn't have to
be stressful you know just use this time
to think about all the good things in
life yeah sugar spice and everything
nice that's basically what a cinnamon
roll is
wow
you're so right there we go perfect
okay
and you actually did that perfectly
because we want to land it on the seam
side down
let's chop off these ends first because
that's just kind of doughy you know you
don't want to eat that i'm going to cut
this in half first
but again i like to eyeball things
so
we'll have i'd like you to cut the first
one just like no sizes i'm just gonna
cut this
rule okay it's actually it looks a lot
more difficult than i thought it would
be
but you know you can kind of reshape it
how cute is that it's really cute we
should name him sammy the cinnamon roll
well we're going to eat you soon but
sorry
now just shove them in
now we can just place them in yeah i
mean there's no rhyme or reason
absolutely strudel oh i love that you
never use that in the kitchen i've never
heard that
all right
perfect look at how cute look at my hair
so cute honestly your hands are probably
going to be really soft so we're going
to cover this up with plastic wrap
so now we wait again
how long this time 30 minutes cinnamon
rolls are an all-day process they are
oh my oh my the thing i love about when
things kind of proof and rise is they
look so much more beautiful because it
kind of fills in the gaps right stuff
and now
it's time to bake oh wow this is the
best part so it starts smelling good
yeah now we're going to bake these for
about 35 minutes in a 350 degree oven
super simple wonderful beautiful ta-da
all right
so now that our rolls are in the oven
we're gonna make our icing so it's
actually super simple just some more
organic powdered sugar this time i
thought that was flour this whole time
i've been looking at it i was like oh
that's why i was looking at it
so i'm actually going to mix it in our
liquid measuring cup because
you can do the honors
almond milk yeah
it smells like nuts huh and then a
little bit of vanilla
it looks like not a lot of liquid but
once you mix it up it will melt
are you ready for this i don't know if i
am i don't know if you are either
they're beautiful they're so cute look
it's sammy
smee so cute the rent of the litter
here's the runt of the litter but you
know i'm sure he's gonna be delicious do
you know what your favorite part of this
cinnamon roll is absolutely i do one two
three it's like having two of her in the
kitchen right you can't come to tasty
and not have a true tasty moment is this
my tasty moment this is this is the
drizzle shot rustic remember what i love
is not like covering them completely
with icing because we still want to see
the spiral they look so good they smell
even better i want to eat one now should
we eat one i'm just going to go at it
with my hands i'm actually going to rip
out oh duh
cheers oh my gosh i'm so excited center
[Music]
i could not tell you that these are
vegan
so much for coming in madeleine i had a
great time rolling with you
right back at you
are you inside i don't know how you sign
up tasty videos tell me what you did
like i you're done